a cylindrical log has a diameter of 12
inches
a wedge is cut from the log by making
two planar cuts that go entirely through
the log the first is perpendicular to
the axis of the cylinder and the plane
of the second cut cut forms a 45 degree
angle with the plane of the first cut
the intersection of these two planes has
exactly one point in common with the log
there the number of cubic inches in the
wedge can be expressed as n pi where n
is a positive integer find n so let's
think about it so let's just draw what
they're describing so we have a
cylindrical log that has a diameter of
12 inches so let's draw that so we have
a so let me draw it like this so that is
a cross section of the log it has a
diameter of 12 inches
so this is 12
12 inches
and it is a cylinder so it looks like
this that is our log
so that is the log in question a wedge
is cut from the log by making two planar
cuts that go entirely through the log
the first cut is perpendicular is
perpendicular to the axis of the
cylinder so it would go it would really
just cut it it would just cut it
straight there's another way to think
about it it's perpendicular to the axis
the axis of the cylinder the axis of the
cylinder goes through the cylinder like
that i don't want to do that and make
the diagram a little confusing if the
log was transparent our cut would look
like this our this first cut would just
go through the log like this it would
really just form kind of a cross section
of the log so that's the first cut the
first is perpendicular to the axis of
the cylinder
and the and the plane of the second cut
forms a 45 degree angle with the plane
of the first cut
so that thing is going to come in at a
45 degree angle so it's going to cut in
it's going to cut into our log something
like that
something
like
that right over there the intersection
of these two planes is has exactly one
point in common with the log that would
be this point right over here
so we need to find the number of cubic
inches in the wedge expressed as n pi
and then we have to figure out n so
let's draw this wedge this wedge that
we've cut out here so this is this right
here is our wedge let me take it out and
kind of flip it around so the base of
i'll make the base of the wedge the
perpendicular cut this cut right over
here so that is the base of the wedge
that is our base
and then you can kind of view the top of
our cut to be the magenta the 45 degree
angle cut so maybe i'll draw it like
this so it would look something like
it would look something like this
trying my best to draw it
it's really the hard part here so let me
draw the 45 degree angle
cut it's going to look something
it's going to look something
like that and where this angle right
over here so if i were to go the
diameter of this top thing it's actually
it's not going to be a normal circle
it's going to be more elliptical but the
diameter of this top thing versus the
diameter of the base which is which is
the diameter of a circle this right here
is going to be a 45
degree angle
now when i first looked at this problem
there's all sorts of temptations here
maybe use some calculus maybe you use
some
you know you rotate something around
some axis to find the volume maybe you
can take you know some type of average
year and you probably could do something
like that but the easiest thing here and
this is kind of you know whenever you
see these kind of competition type math
problems and this comes from the 2003
aim exam
is that there should be a quick way to
do it and if you and and for this exam
in particular you shouldn't have to use
any type of calculus and so if you find
yourself doing something tedious and
hairy you're probably not seeing the
easiest way to do this problem and this
problem is actually ridiculously easy to
do if you just see the trick here and
the trick here is instead of just
directly trying to solve for the volume
of this figure right here take another
one of these guys and put it and flip it
over and put it on top of him so let's
let's say if you did that you would have
another thing on top of it just like
that so if i just took two of these
wedges it would and stack them on top of
each other flipped one of them and
stacked them on top of each other it
would look
it would look like that
this is another wedge right here so
either
i took their kind of angled faces and
put them right on top of each other and
so if you took two wedges together
flip one of them and put it on top of
the other what do you get so the
equivalent i could draw the green wedge
right over here the green wedge would
look like this
where its base
looks like this so what would two wedges
put in this configuration look like well
it's just a cylinder now and it now is a
cylinder
it's now a cylinder so this is a
cylinder with a diameter of 12
so that diameter is 12. but in order to
figure out the volume of a cylinder you
still need to figure out you still need
to figure out the height of the cylinder
you still have to figure out this length
right over here you still have to figure
out what the height is equal to you have
to figure out what this length right
over here is equal to and that's where
the 45 degrees helps us well the 45
degrees already helped us because if you
flip the thing over
and put it on top it forms a nice a nice
cylinder force if it was another angle
it wouldn't have been a nice clean
cylinder like this but the 45 degrees
also tells us what this height is and
let's just think about it here for a
second this triangle that i had drawn in
the beginning let me draw this in i
already used blue let me draw it in
yellow so if i were to take the kind of
diameter of the angled surface
and once again it's not a circle but
it's kind of a stretched out circle and
then i take the diameter of the base
they form a 45 degree angle so this is
45 degrees
this right here is also going to be 45
degrees this length over here we know we
know this length right over here is
going to be 12. now this right here is a
45 45 90 triangle let me draw it like
this i could just draw it like
i could draw it like this
this right here is 45
45 90 triangle you might say how did i
know that's 45 well this is going to be
a right angle right over here and the
sum of the angles have to add up to 180
and then if you have 45 and 90 already
then this one has to be 45 degrees and a
45 45 90 triangles this side is equal to
that side is it not it is an isosceles
triangle the two base angles are the
same so the two sides are going to be
the same so this side right over here is
12 then this side right over here this
side right over here is 12. so the
height is going to be equal to 12. so
let's figure out the volume of this
cylinder that's essentially two wedges
and then we can take half of that to
find the volume of one wedge
so the volume and to find the volume of
a cylinder you just have to find the
area
the area of the top of the cylinder and
to find that it's going to be pi times
the radius squared the radius here is 6
half of 12. so the area is pi r squared
so it's 36 pi
that's that area times the height
times
times 12. and so the whole volume our
volume is going to be equal to what's
that 360 plus 70 let me just multiply it
out i don't make a careless mistake 36
times 12. 36 times 2 is 72
1 times 36 is 36
to
4. so it's 400
432 pi now we have to be very careful
this is the volume of two wedges so this
is a volume of two wedges i could call
it so the volume of one wedge the volume
of one wedge is going to be half of this
let me do this in a different color
the volume of one wedge is going to be
half of this or 216
pi and so if we want to find n because
they say the the number of cubic inches
in the wedge can be expressed as n pi is
216 pi where n is a positive integer
find n well we just figure that out n is
216.